Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier and in this video
I attempt to teach Jack and Felix how to play World of Warcraft.
But, before I do that.
I had to say a short little something.
Because if you didn't know about me, I AM, and have been for a long time...
A legitimate fan of the Warcraft universe.
I've played World of Warcraft since it first came out
and I have sunk literally thousands upon thousands
of hours in-of my life into that game
Uh, but even before that, I was first introduced to Warcraft
because my dad bought it for me.
I can't remember what year it was but...
For Christmas one year he bought me
Warcraft 3 and ever since then I was
hooked on the universe
I loved the Warcraft universe.
There was so much to it. There was so much oozing
lore out of every pore, it was amazing
And I, I just ate it all up and
that's why I got so wrapped up in World of
Warcraft
And some of my best memories
from playing any sort of game
come from World of Warcraft
and playing with my friends in my various guilds
that I played throughout the years,
And just having a good time exploring this BIG, beautiful universe.
SO, the reason I say this is because the
people behind the Warcraft movie,
they came to me and they asked for my help to
help promote the movie
And I am honestly and truly legitimately excited for this.
I don't do these sort of things unless I actually like the thing that I'm promoting.
And in this case, I LOVE the thing that I'm promoting!
It's a rare occurrence where I actually get to tell you guys about something that I'm legitimately passionate about
And I am!
Because I fell in love with the entire universe, an- and the characters in this movie
a lot of people who have played World of Warcraft might not know them.
I mean there's Khadgar in this movie,
but this is like early Khadgar and in the most recent expansion you see him when he's much older,
and much more mature.
There's like Lothar, which not many people know about
there's Durotan, which people may not know about.
And there's Garona who's mentioned in Wrath of (the) Lich King
and may have been mentioned at some
other point in the most recent expansion
I didn't explore every single nook and
cranny so
But these characters, like coming together all doing like...
th--I can't tell you everything about the story or else I would
but I can't spoil anything.
But it's just, it's really cool to see all this history, that I've known for years,
finally come to life in a movie.
And you can say whatever you want about a game vs. a movie
and whether a game should be a movie in the first place.
But what I know is that I love the story behind Warcraft.
And throughout the entirety of my time playing
I've almost never not loved finding out new things about this universe.
I say almost 'cause I can't be overly like joyous about it.
There's been ups and downs! Especially in the World of Warcraft time.
But honestly and truly,
I'm excited about this movie, I'm excited
to play this game with my friends and to
to show them how I love the game
Felix has played a bit but we'll get to that. You'll see in the video you're going to see right now!
And I'll stop rambling so you can get to that funny stuff!
So THANK YOU (random noise) Here we go!
Felix: How do we play the game?
Mark: Oh, you guys don't know?
Felix: No we don't know anything
Mark: Okay...alright.
Jack: TEACH US
Jack: Wait wait we're gonna sit and listen
Mark: *ahem*
Mark: Yeah you'd better get in front of me
Jack: Teach--teach us!
Mark: Better-better pop down, pop a squat
Jack: Teach us mommy!
Felix: *laughs*
Mark: Alright so, here's the deal.
Felix: Mommy no?
Jack: *laughs*
Mark: We're shooting off a lotta green radiation at the moment and that means
Jack & Felix: *giggling*
Mark: Do you want me to give you a lore lesson on why we're irradiated?
Felix: Yes please
Jack: Yeah sure why not?
Mark: Okay! So...
Mark: A while ago...
Felix: I thought we were farting but okay.
Mark: W-we're.. yes we ate a lot of beans and we are currently farting up a storm.
Jack & Felix: *giggle*
Mark: But years ago!
Mark: In Gnomeregan, which is where we are right now, there was...
Jack: That's a clever name
Mark: An infestation...
Of these assholes...
That had gangly arms and were basically stupid dickbags
So...
The smart people in charge decided to irradiate the entirety of the city
Killing everything and everyone
Where everyone had to evacuate...
And now we're all irradiated and we're being rescued
Felix: OH...
Jack: OOOH...
Mark: Got it?
Felix: OH.
Mark: Cool?
Felix: Yeah...
Mark: Okay.
Jack: Yeah! That's very good
Jack: Good explanation!  Good explanation.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: You know how to clahap!
Jack: I KNOW HOW TO CLAP
Mark: Yeaheheheheheeeeee
Jack: Yeah! Good explanation good explanation
Felix: *laughs*
Mark: Now you get your teacher dance!
Mark: Your se~nsual...
Jack: Yeah!
Mark: Teacher da-
Jack: Dance for us!
Mark: Yeahehe
Felix: OHOHO
Mark: *giggles*
Jack: *laughs*
Felix: Oh...YEAH~
Mark: *still giggling*
Felix: AHHH~
Jack: Dem titties!
Mark: You learn good today kiddies!
Mark: (nightmare inducing old man laugh)
Jack & Felix: *laugh nervously*
Mark: Alright now I'm--I'mma turn in the quest for us
'cause thats progress
Jack: We already... what was our quest?
Mark: To kill those assholes.
Felix: To kill six of them...
Felix: Jesus Christ, Jack, are you not paying attention?
Mark: yeah...
Jack: NO~!
Mark: World of Warcraft--
Jack: 'Cause you were supposed to be teaching me!
Felix: OOOOHHH
Mark: I'm teach--I'm teaching you! Listen up
World of Warcraft is a perpetual exercise in murdering as many things as possible.
You will literally travel the world extinguishing all life in every single area you go
Mark: You will not get to an area that you don't have to murder at least a thousand creatures.
Jack: Oh...
Jack: Ok, so it's America Simulator?
Felix: Oooohhhh!  Ohhhhh!!
Mark: [laughs] whoa-hohoho....
Felix: "This is OUR land now."
Jack: It's not the COMPLETE America Simulator.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: This is the most offensive episode of World of Warcraft anyone's seen.
*laughter*
Felix: Thanks Carvo, you're the best.
Mark: [ho-hum like] Yeah...
Felix: Wait, what, how do you level up?
Mark: [laughing] cuz I'm better than you, apparently.
Jack: What??
Felix: What the fuck man!
Jack: Hey!
Felix: You're supposed to be our teacher!
Mark: I don't know -- well, I'm better than you!
Jack: I want a shotgun...
Mark: So obviously I'd level up first.
Felix: That's true, that's true.
Jack: I want a shotgun, those guys have shotguns
Mark: Ok, we have to --we have to act -- alright so these...
Felix: You're a warrior!
Jack: I want ice cream!
Mark: Alright HANG ON!
Felix: Shut up--
Mark: EVERYBODY SHUT UP!
Jack: Are you guys going to level 100?
Mark: Yeah
Jack: This is a bad idea.
Mark: No it's not, shut up, it's fine.
Mark: It'll guide us through the level 100, you'll be fine.
Jack: Sure, this is gonna go well.  [sing-songy] da-da-da-da-daa
Mark: I see you, Boopydoopy.  Come to Mama!
Mark: Come to Mama!
Jack: I'm coming!
Jack: Go open your arms Daddy!
Mark: [screams] Uh--wha-mm?
Jack: I mean Mommy!  I have two axes!
Mark: Mama Daddy?  Dad-mom?
Jack: Are you that white dot?
Mark: I am, yes
Mark: Yaayyy
Jack: Ohh! Hello!
Jack: How did you get that?
Mark: I - I mounted on it
Mark: I mounted it.
Jack: OH.
Felix: You have it too, Jack.
Mark: Yeah, you have it too.
Jack: Where do I--where do I what?!
Mark: Look at your toolbar, you'll see something that looks like an eagle with armor on it.
Click on thaaaaat.
Jack: An eagle wit' armor...
Felix: Omigod, my friiiends! *snicker*
Mark: Hiiiiiii!
Felix: Hey! We look so fucking cool.
Mark: Hey BREHH! Okay...
Felix: Oh!  Oh!  Wait, you have a magic carpet?
Mark: No that's not mine, that's somebody else, that's some other douchebag.
Mark: Ok, so, we are together, and we are the n--
Get the f-- who the fuck is this?  Get the fuck outta here!
Felix: Fight me.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Oh gawd, I have like 50 fuckin' bags now
Mark: Uh huh.  That's good.
Jack: Christ Almighty.
Felix: Oh god... Oh--oh god... Hey!
Jack: I have unspent talent points.  What is happening?!
Felix: You'll never find me.
Felix: God dammit, I don't have any sp-- shit!
Mark: [laughs]
Felix: Shit!  Shit!
Mark: Where ya at?
Felix: Don't worry about it
Jack: Okay... umm...
Mark: There you are.  I see ya.  I see you over there.
Felix: Nope.  You can't find meh!
Felix: Oh don't you dare heal, muddafucka
Mark: [laughing sarcastically] No priest, don't heal!
Mark: How dare you, Priest!
Jack: *laughs*
Jack: Kill him, kill him, kill the small one!
Felix: No!
Mark: Which one?  Which one's the small one?
Jack: That's the thing, I'm being ambiguous.
KILL! KILL! DIE!
Mark: Yeaaaah!  Baammmm! hahahahaa I got him.
Jack: Did you kill him?
Felix: No, he didn't.  He didn't kill me.
Felix: Shut up!
Mark: I got--I got an achievement that said I killed you.
Felix: Oh, okay...
Mark: I got... Bam, baby! Auah, dee-licious!
Jack: Challenge me to a duel, duels start in 3-2-1-go!
Mark: Hit me!
Jack: Kill him!  Aaargh!
Jack: Wuaaagh!  Hrrrrgh!
Jack: I'm just pressing all my... OH FUCK!
[Mark laughs evilly]
Jack: What the -- no!  NO!  Stop it!  Aagh!
Jack:  Stop it!  Lemme alone!  No, no, ow!  Ow!  Ow!
Mark: [evil laugh]
Jack: I don't like this!
Mark: Yeah, those are my boys.  Those are my buddy-boos.
[Jack groans]
Mark: If you wanna fly...
Jack: What's the point of even havin' a griffin?  Suck my--suck my neck.
Mark: Okay. If you--if you wanna fly,
Mark: and be all cool
Felix: Uh-huh
Mark: we can go back to the mainland, and fly there.
Jack: Yes!
Felix: I think we should go.
Jack: Let's do that!
Mark: Alright, follow me,
Jack: Why do I have a sun above my head, and Felix has a moon?
Felix: I put a em' there so we can distinguish who is who
Mark: He p--yeah, he put 'em there...
Mark: Now, we're going to Stormwind because that's closest to where-
[Felix and Jack agreeing in the background]
Felix: Oh, we're going to good ol' Stormwind!
Mark: Yeah.
Felix: Can we go- go- go to Goldshire? Oh my god, yees.
Mark: We could, if- if you got- okay!
Felix: [Indistinct yelling]
Jack: Goldsh-- What ARE these?
Mark: Alright, but just follow me to the mountains right over here,
you get to fly over, see all the cool vistas,
this is where the movie is going to take
place you remember in the trailer you saw
Mark: you saw them fly over and blabla-
Jack: OOH!
Jack: I wanna see that! I don't know much about Warcraft,
Jack: so I wanna know as much as possible before the movie. [Laughs]
Mark: Oh okay.
Mark: WELL, This is Stormwind. It's where the humans live!
Jack: Humans!
Mark: That's all I know about it, okay.
Felix: Oh I remember, the Burning Steps! I remember this place.
Mark: [high pitched voice] Yeah! Exactly, like this is classic-
Felix: HOLY SHIT,
Felix: THE NOSTALGIA, OOAAH
Mark: I know-
[Mark laughing]
Jack: You under those statues?
Felix: THIS IS WHERE I GAINED 60, GUYS!
Mark: [to Jack] No no no, no,
Felix: THIS IS WHERE I GOT 60!
Mark: to the right of the statues.
[Mark and Jack laughing]
Mark: Yeah, I got- I-I hit 60 here too, 'cause I was just grinding ogres.
Felix: Yeah!
Mark: Like, oh, endless ogres!
Felix: OH, those fucking ogres man! So many ogres,
Mark: Oh, man! So many ogres.
[Felix laughs]
Mark: God, fuck those ogres.
Jack: YEAH! Those ogres, am I right!?
Mark: HEY! Fuck you! Those ogres were an ordeal!
Felix: You'll never UNDERSTAND!!
Mark: [angrily] It took DAYS! DAYS! To get from 59 to 60!
Felix: Days!
Mark: DAYS!!
Felix: You know what a big deal it was to get your first mount?!
Mark: Yeah, fuck, I had-
Jack: OH, shut up!
Mark: I had to- I had to borrow gold from one of
Mark: my guildmates just to get enough
Felix: Me too! Hahaha!
Mark: And then I NEVER paid him back, I'm such an asshole.
Felix:  SAME!
Mark: *laughs* Saame!
Jack: SAMESIES.
Mark: *laughs*
Felix: Ohhh, man.
Mark: Here's where things get complicated, because this actually takes some strategy.
See, the big blue stream up there in the orb on the left that that Orc is touching...
Felix: Yes?
Mark: One of us has to touch that orb.
Mark: And then control that dragon on the right.  His name is Razorgore.
Mark: You can't-- You do--
Felix: Dibs on not controlling the dragon!
Mark: You do NOT want to let Razorgore die.  That's the point.  L--Razorgore can't die, or else we die.
Jack: *whines*
Mark: So, what Razorgore does...is Razorgore goes around and he...I THINK he destroys the eggs.
I may be completely wrong abou--it's been YEARS.
Mark: Like, literally years.
Felix: What do we do then?
Jack: Can we just--can we just kill things now?
Mark: Yes.  What'll happen is, I'll get the--OH GOD!
Felix: Whoa!
Mark: OHH GOD!!
Felix: What the fuck did you do you crazy Irish g--
Jack: We're doin' it!
Mark: I'll touch the orb...
Jack: WE'RE DOING IT!!
Felix: Ohh my god...
Mark: Okay, see?  I got Razorgore right here.
Felix:  Okay.  What did you do?
Mark: So now, I can destroy the eggs.
Mark: And--
Jack: Oh, god... What do we do?  Do we protect him?
Mark:  Yeah.  You protect me, because
Jack: FOOLS.
Mark: there's going to be things, uh, comin' around... There's going to be lots and lots of--
Felix: But you're LAYING eggs, dude!
Mark: NO no no no no no, I'm blowin' eggs up.
Mark: I'm blowin' eggs.
Jack: Auh, you're poopin' everywhere!
Mark: No, I'm not poopin'.
Jack: Eh, ya poopin'!
Mark: I no poop...
Jack: You could literally do this on your own, with them constantly attacking you, and you would never die.
Mark: Probably.
Mark: Okay, ba-bahm!  They're all dead.  Okay, so, now...
Jack: ooh!
Mark: NOW we kill Razorgore, I think.
Mark: Noow we kill him...
Felix: No! Not--but he helped--Ohh...
Mark: Well, shit.  Well, fuck.
Felix: I'm rolling "need" on everything!
Mark: Oh yeah?  Fuck you, I'M rolling need...on everything.
Felix: No!  MY epic loot.
Felix: Yeeeah!!  Yeah!
Mark: Oh, fuck that!
Jack: Fuck!  I wanted gloves...*indistinct*
Mark: God, that's so bullshit!
Mark: Now, this encounter was really cool because, um...
Jack: Whoa!
Mark: It was--it was like, this was our friend!
Mark: There's lore behind this.  This was our friend, but he was just corrupted...
And, it's like a race.  You have to kill him so quickly, but we all get this buff that makes us super awesome.
But we're kinda super awesome anyway, so he's gonna die in two hits, but...
*Pffft*
Mark: The whole thing was, we had to--like, this was an endeavor.  You needed five tanks, and you needed to
rotate off of tanks, because each tank would blow up!  Like, you would DIE.
Mark: It was amazing.
Felix: Oh yeah, the tanks would blow up!  I remember that.
Mark: Yeah, exactly.  So you had to rotate five tanks, they all had to stack their Threat Levels,
you had to manage Threat, which is something that doesn't happen anymore, which is really stupid.
Like, I liked it back then when that was actually a thing.
Felix: You don't have to do that?
Mark: No, not anymore!
Mark: Right now, in the game, it's like a tank has Threat...indefinitely.  There's no struggle to it.
Mark: You don't have to manage it.
Felix: Awww, that was the fun.
Mark: I know!!  Right??  Meh, I shouldn't be--
Jack: Guys, shut up!  Shut up!!
Mark: Bahhhm!  Okay.
Felix:  Heey, ep--more epic loot!  Yes..yes...I'll take that.
Jack: I rolled need on everything!
Mark: No, I'm--I'm needing it!  I'm needing it!  Yeah!  YEAH!
Felix:  Yeeeah, I got a belt!
Mark: I got a belt!
Jack: Aww, I got nothin'!
Felix: Wait, Mark?
Mark: Yeah?
Felix: Why does my character not change when I change--do they...seriously look the same?
Felix: Are you fucking kidding me?
Mark: [laughs] I think this one is--
Felix: This is how these epic fucking shoulder pads look like??  Are you fucking kidding me??
Mark: No, I do--I don't think so... Hang on, lemme see...
Jack: [laughs]
Felix: No, that's it.  I remember now.  We got these totally shitty ones.
Mark: Uh... Yeah, no.  Those look like ass.
Mark: Why are those epic? [laughing] Those look like such shit!
Felix: [laugh] Yeah!  I got an epic--oh wait, my should-...
Mark & Jack: [laughing]
Felix: Shoulder pads was like the only thing you could get that looked cool in the game.
Mark: Yeah...and those are just a bag of asses.  But that was--oh, man that's the thing.
they spend so much time on making things look cool that they-they took away the idea of-
I shouldn't criticize.  We're not supposed to criticize, are we? [laugh]
Felix: I-I wanna hear what you're saying...
Mark: No, what I'm saying is, that they emphasize so much on making things look cool and making sure
that everybody could get the cool thing, but that robs the specialness of getting that cool thing,
when everyone can get it, you know what I mean?
Like, things aren't exclusive anymore, things aren't special, and...
...i-it's--I understand the accessibility factor,
But there's something to have something to work for.
Felix: That no one else can have?
Mark: Yeah, a goal.  Like, a big thing that's unreachable.
Mark: And then the people that get them become legends on your server.
Felix: Yeah.  Yeah...
Mark: Ehh, anyway.
Felix: I know what you mean.
Jack: Felix, where're you??
Felix: Uh, I, pff, eh, uh...middle?
Jack & Mark: [laughs]
Mark: Yeah, you wait...you wait for the dragon!
Mark: You get the final blow on the actual...
Felix: I'll tank!
Mark: *giggle*
Jack: Hey!!
Mark: A rogue tank!  Evasion tank!
Felix:
Mark: Yeah. Go~d, I remember that..
Jack: Encourage you to start running...
Mark: The last desperation tank.
Mark:  Jack, what would happen, like if all the tanks die
Jack: *yells something*
Mark: Um, usually--
Felix: Jack, listen!  This is cool!
Mark: Yeah...
Jack: [laughs]
Mark: If all the tanks die, usually the rogues were the next highest on the threat meters.
Mark: So...they have this ability, called Evasion, that gives them 100% dodge chance for like eight seconds.
Felix: Yeah, you have eight seconds.
Mark: And so, it's like... AH!  ROGUE TANK!  GO!
Mark: And then Pet tanks, and then like...desperation tactics, it was so funny.
Felix: Is everyone making a girl?
Mark: Nope.
Jack: *laughs* Mark's making himself.
Jack: Make it hooot, yeeeah...
Mark: Oh yeeah.  Look how hooot my character is.
Mark: *creepy laughter*
Mark: Ohh, yeeesss...*dissolves into laughter*
Jack: Freebewbs.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Theere that's good!  GOD, my THIGHS!  Jesus!  I could crush this fuckin' wolf wit' my thighs!
Mark: I know, right?
Jack: Hey Duil, d'you wanna have a good time?
Mark: Oh, wait--
Mark: Heeey, YOU KNOW I DO.  LOOK AT MAH...EPIC...Amish beard.
Jack: Can you deflect my arrows with your pecs?
Mark: I can deflect them with my bald spot if you'd like. *creepy laugh*
Jack, what're you doin?  Take off your clothes!
Felix: Fine, fine. That'll work.
Jack: How do I do that??
Mark: You just go into your character menu and drag 'em off ya.
Felix: Excellent...
Jack: OH yeeeah! Ahahaha!
Felix: I think this guy is actually flirting with me...
Mark: *laughs* You just...you just take off your pants.
Mark: No, leave the shirt on just your pants, that's all it is
Jack: Oh, god.
Mark: Freebewbs, what are you doing over here, oh my god...
Felix:  This guy is flirting with me!!
Mark: Oh my god... Oh my god!  What is happening?  He's so shirtless!
Jack: Hey! ...We made very similar characters!
Felix: Hell yea, Jack.
Mark:  WHAT ABOUT ME!?  HUH!?
Jack & Felix: Eughh!!
Mark: IS THERE ROOM FOR DUIL??
Jack: Wh-what's our dance like?
Jack: Ooh!  Dadadadadada, dadadadada, da-na-dah! 🎵
Felix: Yeah!  Ahhh, yeeeah, it's a party.
Mark: *giggles*
Jack: Oh!  Nice moves, bro!
Felix: Hell yeah!
Mark: Thanks man!
Mark: YEAH!!
Felix: I'm doing the Macarena...
Felix: Alright, what happens in the Inn stays in the Inn.
Felix: Holy shit!
Jack: OH MY GOD!  WHAT THE FUCK??
Mark: Umm, yeah, welcome to the Inn, guys!  How ya--ya like it?
Jack: Uhh-hu-humm...
Jack: I'm scare-roused right now.
Mark: *giggles*
Felix: This is a very interesting place, guys.
Mark: Yeah, welcome.  Uh...just feel free.  Have a drink.  Take off your pants.  Have a good time!
Jack: My pants have been off for a while now.
Mark: Oh, okay.
Mark: I'll take mine--nah, I'm leavin' my pants on.  You don't wanna see the disaster area that is my grundle.
Felix: Come ooon, don't be such a pusseh.
Mark: Well, fine then, geez.  But I warned ya!
Jack: Take off them pants!
Mark: I haven't shaved in a while!  Theere we go.  *creepy laugh*
Jack: AHH FUCK!  JESUS!!  PUT 'EM ON!  NO!!
Felix: Auughh!  Eugh!!  Put 'em on, dude!  What the fuck?
Mark: I tried to warn ya!
YOU'VE UNLEASHED THE BEAST.